this is my first time sitting down with
you so I'm really excited to meet you oh
thank you how are you Mr Ford I'm very
well good this role was so perfect for
you it suits you the cowboy hat the
horses the cows what else is there what
am I missing everything that the grass
you must have had so much fun bringing
this character to life on screen it is
fun and and uh
um it's great to I like working Outdoors
yeah uh it's pretty cold out there right
now oh yeah it's uh we we're getting a a
taste of what it's like oh to be because
our costumes are are authentic uh and
period and we're out in the weather and
I'm Butte Montana is the coldest city in
the contiguous 48 states and we're we're
out there working in the in the wind and
snow and yeah you really feeling the
pressure of nature on on these people
yeah
Helen Mirren There's Something About Her
Like She's just
so cool like she even talked about being
intimidated working with you when she
did the mosquito Coast I mean how cool
is she how would you describe her
coolness
[Laughter]
I think it's it's one of the aspects
certainly one of her aspects of her
personality but the other things are
she's fearless she's fearless and she's
physically uh Fearless as well and she
just throws herself into stuff and it's
great to watch and it's great fun to be
around her people love the fact that you
guys are back together it's going to be
well you know I I think it's really uh
Taylor's written
beautiful expressions of of
affection
for us and scenes of contests between us
and all kinds of
um
interesting things for us to explore I
love that one of the great things Taylor
has done with this franchise is build
this family tree looking into family
history which I find so fascinating have
you ever looked into your own family
history found anything that was
surprising to you
um
uh
my father was basically orphaned so a
lot of his history is not so much known
uh my mother's family came from Russia
and uh I know a bit about her family but
this is a very different kind of family
and living in a different time and
facing conditions and pressures that
I have I'm I'm unaware of in my family
tree right and you trade in your cowboy
hat for Indiana Jones and for I'm I'm so
excited I'm such a big fan of it at
fifth installment
that theme song must follow you
everywhere you go I mean it's been part
of your life for so long what does
Indiana Jones mean to you personally
uh
it's been very very good to me uh
he's uh you know it's a it's a wonderful
character and and the series has uh been
uh
very successful I'm very grateful for
having that opportunity you've worked
thank you George thank you George thank
you Stephen thank you Stephen you're
Stephen and thank you Jim mangled
what was the last name Jim Mangold is
the director of the latest iteration of
Indiana Jones I love that
um you've worked with some incredible
directors production teams writers have
you ever kind of had a chance to sit
back and reflect on the
the dent the massive Dent that you've
made in cinema
no I mostly think about the dent that's
made in me
[Music]
hasn't made a dent in you
you know
this one and that one right here yeah
you know just sitting here with you I
just got to tell you
um my dad hasn't been doing so well
recently and you have created some well
many emotional uh amazing memories with
me and my dad he used to say Mr Ford's
on television we've got to sit down and
watch and um but he didn't call me Mr
Ford he did oh come on he did Mr Ford he
loved you and um I just want to say
thank you just I'm sorry I don't know
where that came from but I just want to
say no I'm very grateful for that we're
very grateful and I think that's one of
the elements of that has supported me uh
in this career
is that that I've made some family films
that are passed on uh from generation to
Generations kind of
introduce me to new uh a new audience
thank you I thank you